we forgot to tell you guys that after we
podcasted last Monday mm-hm
we had a heck of an evening heck of an
evening with a pup boats with a dog what
happened was I'm not gonna say any more
animal stories I'm not gonna say names
I will not implicate me because it was
an accident mm-hmm it was an accident so
our friend of ours husband came to do us
a favor to clean out to take these
cabinets we have these cabinets that
were built into the house that we didn't
want we we want to get rid of them he
wanted the cabinets so he came with his
truck and so we put the cabinets in our
back yard
and he opened we have one gate in our
back yard that opens to the street okay
and he pries open the back gate with um
he props it open with a little stool to
carry and then he put it in his truck
and then he drove off without closing
the back aide so they get back gates
completely open and so you know every
what what I do is that back gate there's
an alleyway don't describe the house too
much I'm not going to it but there's an
alleyway that leads to this back aide
and I like to throw balls with the dogs
it's like a giant dog run it's a dog run
yeah and I throw the ball they run it
hits the back gate bounces off of it and
so they don't escape you bring the ball
back and it's good exercise for the dogs
and so I go let's go come on dog it's
why we have goby and Julio let's go boy
boy girl and I bring the dog and as I
throw the ball and I realize after I
throw it the gates completely open so I
go ah [ __ ] and I just see these two dogs
run out into the street Wow now go be
you know go be is one way go be is our
daughter dog she's a good dog he's a
good easy to retrieve back good recall
no recalls you know it isn't is good
with other human beings and then we also
have a psychopath Julio we have an
absolute homicidal like if it was a
human it would be in a straitjacket
Kevin Spacey in the movie 7g yeah yes
that's Julio Julio our only loves
Julianna the only person he loves is
Julian I don't know why but um and and
and Julio at nights doesn't sleep with
us all the animals want to sleep with
you know mama and papa but Julio refused
to sleep and wants to sleep with Juliana
because when Juliana visited us years
ago she raised him she raised Julio as a
puppy so Julio just recognizes seas of
Juliana as a as a mother I guess which
is it's heartfelt so the dogs run out in
this [ __ ] Street right and oh my god
chaos ensues okay Bobby nearly got tased
Bobby got a so Julio goes up to a woman
doesn't bite her but she's wearing a
blouse and a scarf no it was a scarf
yeah like a big scarf and she's pulling
her scarf off her [ __ ] body and she's
screaming and then Julio runs up the
street right and goes up to this
gigantic dog I don't know what kind of
dog it is but it starts biting its legs
and the owner the owner of the dog pulls
out a Taser a human taser not a dog
taser and starts trying to zap Julio
geeky and I'm running around the sky
what are you eating this app right and
trying to [ __ ] get Julio I grabbed
him he bites me here right yeah as hard
as he can't and I grabbed him by the
neck and I'm holding him and also dude
I'm fat right and Bobby's in his
underwear with no shoes underwear no
shoes I look like a madman Yeah right
and I grabbed him and literally dude I
get him in the house and I it was almost
as if you know years ago I saw a
horrific car accident and I couldn't
shake it it was silver
somebody died in this car accident that
I saw and it felt like anything oh yeah
it was terrible I can I tell you the
story this is really dark yeah I was at
my I want to say her name but I was at
my friend's house and she's a
Groundlings oh yes you did tell this
story I know this story but tell it
again so she's a Groundlings actress you
know she's very talented
and she used to date my friend Peter and
she's a friend of mine and I was at her
house at like midnight 12:30 at night
and she lived in Silver Lake on a hill
and all of a sudden we hear a car crash
and we look down we can see it and a car
had around a corner and hit a brick wall
dead on I think they were trying to know
what there were three people in this car
the car was flipped upside down and by
looking at it you're just like whoever
was in that car is not alive yeah but
what the horrifying thing was is I guess
a girl in that car right her sister was
following them in another car oh so she
watched it so she pulled over and she's
screaming at her sister and and all we
could do is just stand that we call the
cops
obviously you don't find one one and we
got the cops there but I remember
staying there till like 5:00 in the
morning you know I mean just in absolute
shock I mean obviously the júlio
incidence is not as that's not the same
thing no I'm telling you about feeling
oh yeah feeling yeah in terms of feeling
fight-or-flight yeah feeling of like you
know um you know shock I don't know no I
know what you mean like where it takes
you like a couple hours to decompress or
you're still kind of like no it stays
with you for days right it's a it's an
adrenaline like you have a surge of
adrenaline just take over your body and
after that it's just as it was the guys
say now afterwards to you guys it was
like complain at all no we got the cut
we got the dog back in the house and we
just didn't leave the house for days go
be globalist Kobe was easy to get cuz as
soon as I call her she just comes to me
and also Kobe doesn't bite and it was
really scary cuz it's not like you know
if Julio gets out it's not like we could
be like Oh some neighbor found him
he's not a friendly dog he really is
like not okay in the head it's hard
because when we have friends over or we
have to keep in mind that we have this
dog so we have to put Kobe in the in the
kettle or we have in the kettle or
whatever it's all not cook we're not
very Freud that's a Bigfoot isn't
slipping
what's a kettle like a cooking thing
cooking mechanism all that a kettle in
the cage yep I try to do a fancy word
for cage but kennel kennel oh the slurp
King is so dumb Dom you know but here's
the thing when you own animals and this
is I guess this is how I you know
Jeffrey Dahmer's father you know Jeffrey
Dahmer when he was dissin okay when he
was in trial his dad visited him at
prison every day and sat by him every
day and supported a son and walked
through this I feel that with Julio you
know I'm there for my son know even
though he's got the wild I he's got the
wild eyes he's got the life for sure but
you know if he gets to know you like has
he ever been anything but sweet with
George or you know sweet with me not
with George he just likes oh yes no no
just the one time we were had him in the
podcast room when he was still a puppy
and I had to try to hold him so he
wouldn't like gnaw on the side of the
table then make noise and he kept on
reaching around and biting me and then
Bobby got mad at me for making noise and
not like being completely quiet Gilbert
we have an unhelpful advice well I have
a question before that really quick
people have been wondering do you've any
gripes with Rudi this week Oh
pipes with Rudy well alright with Ruthie